this is the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm joined by the cofounders of this is
prime I've got Neil Clough to the right
of me and Nicole Kingston to the right
me as well just practice at about free
time it's a good start
yeah that is a good start so as I just
saying guys we're are always always like
to start with this podcast is how the
hell the both of you entered the world
of recruitment let's start there and
then we'll uncover there this is prime
story sure do you wanna go for this
so my journeys recruitments a little bit
different I did ten months of it quite a
number of years ago and God be honest
didn't really enjoy it I would just call
it a learning period of my career and I
did set once of it and then got an
opportunity to go into kinda like a
management position which is what I
wanted to do yeah in the way of industry
which had always been in mmm and then my
kind of weird journey took me on to the
BBC apprentice yeah which saw me fail
again actually so unfortunately he
didn't quite win but what it did was
made me learn about what I should do
what I wanted to do into into the
business it's actually Lord Sugar they
give the advice with sticks of what you
know and not what you want to know and
that was sales that's all never done for
20 years yeah and getting young people
into sales that's why the recruitment
came about for me really okay cool yeah
slightly different and so for myself I
started off my career I didn't go to uni
went straight into telesales and then
went into recruitment like the usual
people fell into it did high street
recruitment start off with manpower
Kelly's they were into more niche
recruitment
[Laughter]
and then eventually I moved more into
training and then followed sort of sales
training career before then setting up
my own training company where most of my
client base quickly became equipment
okay cool so then just to frame it up
for everyone just to make it clear so
kneel for you after the the apprentice
how sitting off that did you then start
this is prime I'm about yeah yeah yeah I
say okay like a consultancy stroke
training business for six months to be
honest just to make some money on the
back of doing the apprentice which was
great and then realized that it wasn't
scalable it was more about people
wanting to be trained off a guy you got
fired from the apprentice weirdly so I
wanted to create something where I could
do something different where people
wanted to work and we can make a
different impact and get in you know
people into sales which is a career that
people still look down upon that I was
really keen to change that stigma and I
met Nicole because she was training at a
time and similar vision for her she
wanted to do something different she
wanted to change the stigma that's
attached to say how did you meet each
other tell the true story around it and
the call was following me on Twitter I
wasn't just following and then actually
had to go with me cuz I read an e-book
and told me how bad it wasn't as well
absolutely so where to be fair that's
that's how it came about you asked for
honesty bank so I gave your honest
feedback yeah I there was quite a lot of
people that downloaded an e-book there
in only because world sugar tweeted that
my right man now as a the right plan
choosing sounds but shows the power of
social media there's 18,000 hits on the
website within the half an hour
really off it off his Twitter basically
so I've written this the ibaka for it
was pretty good my spelling is
absolutely terrible yeah and I asked for
some feedback on it I've done a why did
ducks I don't like feedback that's the
only thing you know everyone asks for
feedback
did 99 of them was like you know this is
amazing obviously didn't read it and one
of them was like you know a spelling
mistake improver 18 19 20 and 21 so when
I checked out who it was it was Nicole
and she started Malaysia pretty much
Erin just sound that we both were really
passionate about training young people
educating them on sales and trying to
get more people into the industry and
you know that's what we've been all
about now for the last five years okay
and then for yourself then the card is
fair run yeah obviously obviously you
took a different pathway so you was a
sales trainer businesses yeah for how
long so I literally I'd worked in a
number of corporate businesses my last
one was virgin sales training there for
seven years and then I'd set my own
business so I set up and I had it from
2011 and that's when I really found that
my niche market was recruitment because
of my network the amazing thing with
recruitment you never lose your network
so matter how long you're out of it so
it was a really good opportunity start
well we've got and I think at that point
the training was going really well but
what you tend to find when you're doing
sales training is all your clients
always say to you who do you know that
might be looking for a job who do you
make so you're kind of missing out on a
fee as you always recommend in people
yes and I think that's pretty much where
we got to rely it was asking us all the
time but also when you're training
people like well who's gonna be really
good who the superstars in the session
and nine times I'd tell you pretty much
nail it and you know who's gonna do well
and who is in but you always know that
somebody's looking for someone so yeah I
mean that's not a bad way to start
businesses it when people telling you we
need this help and you solve this matter
and you start a business around that you
know I mean I think it's only people
todays well now start business says it's
a best idea but then have no ideas
people right you can engage with it all
yeah beforehand you're not mean so just
fair run this and then who may not know
and prime so what is the actual from
what I understand you train people on
sales or or see you will be able to
explain it and then you take them to
recruit me businesses is that right yeah
yeah pretty much
so you run training academy
and is it always people without sales
experiences that people with sales
experience and we are target audiences
graduate training market so we work with
anyone that's looking to get a career no
job and we have a really thorough
process so the whole purpose of prime
was to change the perception of sales
but make recruitment and answers a
career choice rather than a career that
everyone just falls into it's not
promoted as a career when people go to
uni who don't go and go and I really
want to come up with in a recruiter but
actually it's an amazing career if
you're given the tools and the skills to
be successful so then the gap in the
market we saw was a lot of people fail
in recruitment a first year often
because they either don't understand the
role in the first place
or they haven't been given the training
to be successful so we kind of tried to
take that away and go let's offer a
quality service don't be one of those
businesses that just spams out CVS let's
invest the time so we're not a volume
recruiter we're much more quality leads
and we train our candidates before we
place them and then a lot of our clients
use our training post placement yeah
that was my next question just for my
benefit where does the trend stop so do
you get involved with train and actually
have them training actual people who
have a user experience or whatever do
you get involved at that or yeah a lot
of our clients use our training services
separate as well so we offer recruitment
and training as an option or
individually reason I think our clients
buy into it's because we do bespoke
training rather than off-the-shelf so we
tailor it to what they're looking for so
is more value to it and so we'll have
clients that will perhaps put a group
together where they'll have their
directors in it their managers in it
their trainees in it because they want a
consistency there that everyone's
working till the same thing so they all
know what each other expectations are
okay that's good tonight so and
obviously the both of you sort of have
the Hat so did you ever have your own
business before now just just just after
you princess to be honest really which
is where I had I suppose the courage to
go out there and got my own and prior to
that had always been working in sales
oh yeah
Nicole you already had an experienced
annamund business yeah so I guess how
was the house the first year that I was
like to talk about that because she had
this amazing idea seems like everyone's
gonna pay money for it but how I was
actually that first year or now going to
your clients look we can actually help
you how how was that journey this is
probably gonna be a bit of a curveball
for people out there but for me the
first year is the easiest really because
you're not up against growth so
everything you do is is growth at the
end of the day it's all about
scalability everything is fresh
everything is new you are going to have
more passion than you've ever had before
to make it work because you know you've
just left your job or you've done
something to make it happen and usually
there's only one or an hour case two of
you so it's so excited the challenge
comes right now when you're five years
in you've got 20 employees and and kind
of it's all hard to manage so for me the
most enjoyment is the first people think
it's great well you'll know because well
yeah yeah six six months in I think the
bit that I would just add to that is
that I it was always sort of my plan but
I love the fact that the complete
responsibility is on me to deliver what
I sell to my client yes do you know I
mean right now see you have 19 20 heads
obviously that's sort of out your
controllers a bit more now isn't it then
in terms of what can be delivered to
your clients in the end results that's
what I've realized in last six months
there if it isn't as good as I said it
was of well that that's on me and I'm
actually quite comfortable that true and
I'm in control of that yeah the day yeah
so no I think I love the way that you
put our guess what about yourself Nicole
do you agree with that or yeah I think
what was interesting that first year was
we both really competitive people really
yeah and we hate failure we like succeed
so I think our first year we didn't
really have a plan it was more about
let's just hit targets make money make
it happen and then got you into it we're
like okay we've done that but we
actually trying to do did you have a
business plan we thought we hadn't
realized we did
I'm not planning on his paw I think that
was the biggest learning curve we had
we've got non-exact director involved
who is you know not a recruiter but
proven entrepreneur and to be fair you
know the biggest advice we got probably
going into year two stroke year three
you need you need support just make it
happen and we did and we put a plan in
place which would just come to the end
of it for five years
and because of that we've gone on and
overachieved on everything that we said
we how is that helping having a plan
because I think there'll be a lot of
people listening who may be thinking
master on their own recruitment business
or whatever and I've already had this
conversation quite a few time because a
lot of people are spoken to you who are
now a sort of way around maybe fifteen
to ten heads twenty hands or whatever
did start the business not knowing
exactly what it looks like yeah because
it can be quite hard to visualize
especially in the months that you have
on I've had the exact same one set like
let's just start get money in the bank
and we'll see what happens
yeah I guess like how if you obviously
seemed like if we were to go back and
start again you would think about okay
how would we want this to look a year
from now two years from now would that
be beneficial for people thinking about
that yes I think it does but at the same
time you plans
good if you if it's achievable it's
realistic and I think when you start a
business I think the biggest issue you
know we had was if we're really honest
it was like right first year we're going
to do a million quid and it was like
actually no it's gonna take a couple
years I think that's the difference and
then what you do and this is that the
biggest you know advice I would give
starting you put these targets together
and you put you're always recruitment
salespeople or confident people right
yeah we do so actually we're always
gonna think we can go through as much
every single target as soon as you pull
that target in place and then you don't
start achieving it one month and then
the next month but then you are oh my
this is we're doing really bad here and
the reality is you're not it's just that
you've probably been so optimistic in
your targets they weren't achievable in
the first place yeah so I think puns are
good absolutely nothing now the stage
we're in you have to have a business
plan in place yeah
but for the first year it's about
enjoying it it's about going out there
and making a difference and doing what
you can't
I think oh yeah I think that there is an
element that I think you also one thing
we learnt was if you're going into
business someone you don't really know
yeah as well without a plan you have two
very different perspectives on what what
success looks like what you're trying to
achieve and I think that's what our
beliefs LEM one of them was in the first
year was that we thought we were on the
same page and got in the room completely
different views on what we were trying
to achieve how do you have you both got
better that things there'll be a lot of
people listening that one don't like the
idea of starting their own to like the
idea of start with someone else has it
been communicating better or I don't
know what you do now do you have like
monthly catch ups or well I tell you all
do I'll give the positive no I think
nothing the positive and again I get
asked quite a bit about when they're
doing talks or whatever it is about you
know what advice would you give to
someone trying to start business yeah
and one of the bits of advice I'd always
give is you should partner up with
somebody and you should partner up with
somebody that's got different skill set
to you yeah which gives you a more
rounded skill set as a business sure we
are different in the way whether we look
at things but that means that we usually
get to the right conclusion at the end
so for me partner Robbie's gray listened
to one of your podcast recently the
gentleman was was on his own and his
advice was if you had this time again
imparted yeah so true kids imagine when
things are great you just celebrate with
when things aren't so good who do you go
to whichever the toughest time so I do
think having a partner is important but
having somebody that has a different
skillset to you is equally important to
give you you know best skills though so
I think just ran that off its light also
may make sure you know your strengths
absolutely not I mean yeah now on to the
negatives is challenging really
challenging I think we all we are both
quite strong characters stubborn as well
I think we both think we're both right
all the time so it's good in the fact
that you come with so many different
ideas and you will always get to an end
result but actually sometimes
isn't what either of you came up with
yeah but you have to battle that out to
get to the end result and I think just
trying to keep things focused and not
think you're always right and don't run
before you can walk
that's why I think it's worked really
well having a non exec as well because
the tools may disagree or agree that
sort of things but having a non exact
there you've got that person to go
listen you know let's go this way go
that way when did you engage in a non
exec at the start yeah three was
involved and was that intentional yeah
really yeah again that I think that's
pretty good advice as well isn't that
nothing more so as well I like the idea
of having someone know in the
recruitment world because I think that's
obviously there's pros and cons to that
as well but I think having someone there
may not have worked in recruitment but
has a good business acumen it's
beneficial obsequies it's again I'll see
someone that will see you only lives and
breeders will groom it if 50 million
years ago do you know I mean yeah you've
gotta know your skill set and yeah and
you know where we'll both openly admit
you know scaling a business isn't what
we've done before mm I've been inside a
Salesman Nicole had been a trainer for a
number of years how great businesses but
we'd never scaled the business so having
someone there that can give us that
guidance ie you need to make sure the
plans in place you need to execute any
different advice has helped us grow and
so yeah I'd strongly recommend it but I
get it again it's about having the right
person yeah yeah I think when you're in
recruitment as well though there it's
the most networked industry so if you
want to get advice or information or
guidance from people you'll always find
someone in recruitment that's willing to
have a chart organ like just there's so
many groups and networks where is
getting outside perspective on a
business rather than it just being about
recruitment who's been massively
beneficial for us yeah okay first year
then was it just you to the end of the
year still no five really yeah I'm
ravenous well interestingly our process
is quite unique so we do a training day
which didn't graduate for your and yeah
so we obviously for our for our clients
we were on trade
days where coins come and observe people
being trained and he selects who they
live from the process is it's a it's a
kind of bringing the traditional
Assessment Center into the modern era is
look at it by training people yeah we
did our own training day in the first
kind of few weeks of setting up
we hired Kyle who's that the press which
Prince is a part Manchester if you
listed it we came to our training day
the time we was on there it was quite
interesting things on the back of doing
the BBC apprentice wasn't it so we had
quite a lot of people like coming here
and there was like a guy from Bulgaria
came over there was like this guy who
could speak Mandarin there was an
ex-professional man city football and
then there was Kyle from Prestwich and
to be fair that was a difference that's
where we knew we had to recruit on our
values on our culture and we recruited
Kyle who now is five years in it's a
sales manager he's going on to be a
director in the business mazing piece of
advice we were given again from our
Knights it was you start a business with
your values so what is it you're trying
to create
so our first real challenge was what is
the vision like what do you want to
create and and we established we wanted
to create a business where people wanted
to work like people wanted to join our
business everyone wanted to work there
and then we looked at what were the
values that would make that happen both
for internal perspective but worked
externally as well with difference and I
think from that everything we did was
always underpinned with the values so
anything we make a decision on we're
always told does it fit with our laws is
it aligned and if it isn't don't do it I
think managers can be quite like just a
bit overlooked now in just a bit like
yeah like you saw need them but then you
know I mean I think my people can very
easily end up with values a like
professional integrity honest or the
normal staff but are you someone that
lives a breeze but as you said makes
business decisions on those values and
that's why they're there that's what I
mean what they mean yes the education
piece around it of do you actually know
what the values mean and why they're
there and as long as people know what I
mean and how to deliver on them then you
always have alignment even if people
don't agree they pull each other on the
values yeah
and we'll feedback when you do is why I
remember the first time we we had to
meet with the no exactly right the first
thing we do with his business if you set
a vision and you values and we did this
three-hour exercise with him about it
and at the time I'm thinking this is
just cheesy yeah values whatever it's
and now if I'm completely honest
everything we do is around value and
vision it was the best thing we ever did
so I'd advise people do it the very
think about that yeah that's wicked and
then don't just do it for for doing it
sake light as you said god bleep yeah
really commit to it and so you gave
yourself you had you wanted to do a
million quid revenue how'd you do in the
first year absolutely from a standing
start
it's what we wanted to do I had it all
and it be no criminal clients yeah we
all graduate rhetoric it's now year five
that we we're kind of 50/50 back to
record and sales recruitment which meant
always the plan and what's the just to
give me some context the sales piece
what types of world ladies a lot
financial sales and tech sales or is it
just sales yeah predominantly tax sales
bought everything that every company we
partner with is companies that are going
to invest in young talent will develop
them through and there has to be
training structures in place because the
retention rates generally the reason why
we set this business up are so poor and
graduate recruitment going to sales
because of the pressurized environment
and so yeah we wanted to change that and
last year you know I think our proudest
moment of all is although we smashed our
financial targets 90% of our placements
last year I passed the probation because
you know and that to beat sores is the
biggest advice and we said it all five
years ago to make a difference and a
change and last year and they're going
up even though the volume of placements
going on yes cool okay right so with
that in mind as well or what did you
start in Manchester and have your office
because of so we're in London today
so again when did you open the London
office
I'm year three so we did first three
years in Manchester London's just
finished its second year really okay
cool so you two - you're free mmm what
was that like year two ta three I think
that's when you know you've got
something good you've proven it you've
tested there and that's where the
pressure comes because then like I said
you're up against growth it's expected
yeah and for me that's when I think the
pressure really started to come in that
you know you then got employees you go
to you know eight nine ten people mmm
you've got responsibilities no matter
when you work a business you know your
business is built on your people well
the same time your biggest challenges
are you people so yeah things have
changed for us dramatically at that time
I would say really what grads what's
that perception of recruitment well
probably if I'm sure that's change
probably mine when I left up it said
yeah yeah well I'm sure it's changed a
lot has it changed from that year one if
you think of the people that you have in
those training days to now what's the
typical perception of a grant of
equipment initially not great yeah it's
an education piece isn't it everyone has
a perception until you change that
perception yeah
our whole praise this is about
identifying what they want from a career
identifying what their characteristics
and traits are as an individual and then
going does that match this industry and
if it does then educate on what the
industry is all about what the
challenges are but also what the rewards
are if you're good at it and then bring
in through a process that allows them to
get to see that firsthand what are the
traits characteristics I my number one
someone asked me this the other day
hands down his work ethic really yeah
without doubt come up a lot recently
yeah I think people underestimate how
hard you have to work to be successful
in that first year to two years and
that's where people struggle always
bring this up because I love getting
people's different opinion on their work
ethic now in 2019 2020 I don't know for
me I just feel like today's well my mind
and I feel a lot of people's minds
straights a lot late hours no flexible
work in yeah no dogs in the office when
you say work ethic grad now or do you
not mean a young person in today's
webinar just feel like they're the
things that are attached to work I think
I think I don't know like what thing if
they look as change there's a lot of
stigma around graduates isn't there I
think the reality is the society that
they've grown up in is very different to
what recruitment used to be like 20
years ago so they don't have the same
outlook on certain things so if if a
graduate wants to learn something or no
so they can know it straight away you
ask Google you are serializable exit
things are instant if you order
something it comes next day recruitments
not like that it doesn't happen
overnight it's not that quick so
patience is a big thing and it's making
me recognize that you know what you're
not going to see an instant return
you're not going to see a quick return
you're not gonna see a quick win it's
about longevity so our education piece
when we do our training session a lot of
it is around mindset and going it's an
amazing career but you've got to work
hard that first year you're gonna have
to make sacrifices if you want to be
really successful but it's about being
smart with your time as well like you
could work less hours than somebody else
but if you're literally working those
hours and not getting distracted and
losing focus you'll be far more
productive so it's your choice at the
end of the day how many hours really
you're gonna have to put in based on
what you do with the hours it's so easy
in today's world I could sort of be
someone outside looking into your
business to go up prime I didn't write
on there do you know like she's so easy
to see where you want to five years now
our Open Office here doing well whereas
it's when we're difficult now to see or
people aren't willing to share all the
stuff that leads up to that the
challenges absolutely the graft and work
effort you know I mean it's so easy just
to see the finished result yeah and not
see that how do you sell recruitment
these people because I love the way that
you're talking about it I think I've
always been open around sort of my story
it was always sold to me around just the
good parts right and I think a lot of
people and I sold just the good parts of
recruitment
how obvious you're talking about
patients talking about work ethic talk
about mindset which is brilliant what
how did what how would you say you sort
of cell recruitment to these people we
sell them out of it really yeah so you
know we're not about obviously we're
about volumes of placements cuz we want
to grow em we'd rather make good
placements our biggest we don't we don't
work to KP ice it's not we do but
obviously we work to some targets but we
don't make the guys doing XML cause or
meet X amount of people because it
drives the wrong mentality what we do
work on quality because that 90% success
rate is what we want to continue to grow
so for us what we want is people the 50%
of people the for our recruitment didn't
want it in the first place and so what
we try and do is work that our in the
interview process or we put the model
for people yeah I was speaking to one of
the what we what we do is we're we're
more honest probably without job adverts
for a start I spoke to one of them
really you know market leading job
boards not so long ago and they were
like you know you need to get more
applications what you need to do is put
you know the bracket range from 18 K
which is a base you know to like 40 or
50 K because you've got to get more
people they hired a mic well that's not
what they're gonna work well yeah well
that's the OTE whoever does that in the
first year is probably the top 10% on
people that have done recruitment you're
not going to earn that you're gonna wear
mid 20s if you're doing well and that's
being realistic because you've got it
you've got to work hard so we're more
honest from where he starts we're more
honest about the fact of you know the
average you have to put in and
everything else and if you're honest at
the start and put people off and they
still come back and want it and then
they come to the training event and then
they do another interview they're more
likely to go into that job thinking
actually this is for me and that's what
we do is start really so rather than
sell them in we sell them out and of
course we've got through our job or you
want to place people that are going to
be successful and we're all about
changing that perception and making
careers with people not people that go
in our free jobs in a year so if we sell
them into it too much we're not doing
the right thing so that's what we tend
to do you know you I mean I've had a cop
people on this podcast share this or
grad Assessment Center experience and it
sounds pretty grim sound really bad yes
it's to sell the person so the person
next to its you see it wrong it's brutal
it's absolutely brutal and we set this
up and we look to the well-known
competitors that do it and don't get me
wrong they do some things amazingly well
and they probably make more placements
and all some of the market leaders but
what they don't do is have that
retention rate and that retention rate
is purely there because the training
development and taking care and showing
people a downsize as well as the upsides
of the industry because it's not for
everyone is it and I mean people people
don't go to you choose wanting to be a
recruiter at the end of it they fall
into it but yours if they knew more
about it before going to uni and saw it
as a career for me he's given me
entrepreneurial skills so have yourself
a business then people may choose it and
we're just about trying to get more
people actually working on it as a
career rather than kind of thinking oh
god I can't get anything else I'll flop
it's a recruitment hmm so what just to
sort of finalize that but you can talk
about what it's like now and stuff but I
think you just mentioned the car around
there definitely is a misconception of
grasses in there in terms of yeah I mean
you can talk about then I was willing to
work as hard or instant gratification
wherever it may be what what do you
think is the sort of biggest
misconception from your point of view
from working with law grads I think
they've all just put under the same
bracket on there we've got a really
strong team and what we've identified is
that they don't fit that mold or don't
want to work hard or don't want to do
the long hours there's a lot of people
that do it just comes down to what
people want and what they're prepared to
do to achieve it so it's what you're
looking for in individuals it is a bit
cliche there but you're looking for
those driven those ambitious people
those people that don't want to fail
they want to be successful but they also
have not just a money motivation but a
success desire as well so it's finding
the right characteristics because they
genuinely think it's a perception that's
across the majority but it's probably
the minority the candidates we speak to
our process is so thorough that it's all
about getting to know them as
individuals and then looking for the
right traits that we we all know what
makes
a great recruiter great it's finding
those traits within those individuals so
we've got a team where they're not
afraid to work long hours they're not
afraid to pick up the phone the evening
get on the phone at the weekend if they
have to because they want to be
successful we're not saying you've got
to do it they're choosing to it because
success is important to them just about
you tend to find people and from doing
what we do and this is probably a tip
people interview and outside of what we
do so is people who've made a sacrifice
to further their self all-knowing career
doesn't have to be career for example
people that are moving to London because
they feel that with that the hope of the
world where they're going to make the
best impact yeah they've got more fire
in the belly they're moving away from
the friends people who've made a
sacrifice for their career tend to make
great recruiters because so driven on
the end goal rather than people that
might want an easy life and that's fine
if you do what recruitment is tough
you've got to be willing to make
sacrifices and put the hours in
particular in your first year hmm and I
think now that that is interesting
Laurie said that I think so back to the
business then year to year freak soon
year five now yeah if we talk about year
to year to year for just finished your
fifth year right yeah year to year for
I'll see ads you said real proof of
concept that I mean yeah done great in
terms of revenue in terms of for the
year one what what then went on over
those the last copy is in because like
because how many competitors do you have
because I feel that when once I've
learned a bit about you guys it's a lot
[ __ ] it just made sense you know I'm
in so I guess how yeah how did how did
those years ago and what were some of
the sort of ups and downs there Wow I
think we touched on it before I think
the you know it's different now we're at
you know 20 heads and have that is a
great an amazing thing to have you know
so many people that are working in your
business that are passionate about what
we're about doing changing that
perception of sales and doing something
a bit differently but at the same time
you know we we also got a team of
Millennials when the call was mentioning
Haitian wants to progress quickly so I
think managing people is probably been
the biggest challenge and you take you
take on grands yeah absolutely
okay so let's talk about that then
because I think if it falls into why are
eliminating C's so bad it'll cream for
themselves there's you know I mean
that's that's the problem that you're
aiming to solve as well as the
perception of recruiting these sorts of
things and yeah like let's talk a bit
about some of the learnings of there I
mean I haven't sat down with many people
in this podcast I don't think who solely
just hire grads I think I always end up
having a conversation with people that
have not sure on experienced hires
because they're for either competence
your bad habits or whatever
people love before taking someone that's
yeah grad or some sales experience
because they can mold them to whatever
that is whatever they have so I guess
for yourself in your own business then
what what have been some of the
learnings of managing people that's been
a challenge I think it's an interesting
one because obviously we working in
recruitment and most of our clients will
always say if you've got any one
experience last night about them but
good recruiters are hard to come by
because if they're great they're being
looked after really well so they're
they're few and far between and I think
the the view of a business owner is like
if I bring in some of the experience yes
is a risk they've got bad habits they
might have burnt out but there's also
the advantage that they know what
they're doing they can hit the ground
running they can start making money fast
whereas bringing a trainee they've got
no proven track record you don't know if
it'll work or not you've got invest a
huge amount of time in and train them
developing them and you're not
guaranteed a return so I think there's
that massive concern of is it is it
gonna work or isn't it but I think my
view is if you're taking a trainee and
you give them the right development you
can make it work
our results are proven that it can work
and I think getting it right is never
easy but one thing we've learnt with
that graduates market is progression and
development of probably the most
important things to them everyone thinks
it's money and success yes they're
important but they've just come out
learning for three or four years and
they're in
learning mentality and if they go into a
role and then they just go right here's
the product this is what we do this is
our market but they're not shown or
taught how to sell it they very quickly
go right well and nobody is but I don't
know how to do the job then that's when
they start to go well it's not working
for me and then he'll go right
recruiting graduates just doesn't work
it's not it's not the right way fall
ways but I think our biggest learn has
if you invest in them and I'm not
talking about classroom training all the
time the best learning happens on the
job giving your management team the
skills to be able to coach and feedback
on the job really well will make them
really effective really quickly because
I don't want to sit in a classroom all
day they want to be doing the job they
want to learn by doing but feedback
real-time is probably the most critical
tool you can have it fair to say them
one of the key the key loans are for you
guys then is having a bit of a sort
clear career progression structured
communicator you are today this is where
we'd like to be this is what you can be
a bla bla bla I think make that sort of
crystal clear for the people you bring
in your business so it's back back that
I believe and I can only go from my own
goals but at the same time more and more
for Millennials anyway the progression
is probably more important than money
and I think actually when you get asked
that question progression or money
really it's the same thing right yeah
but for me regression works really well
one thing that we did which I think was
a big step change in the business which
changed the promotional criteria and
again it's probably not a bit of advice
of people that go in from maybe ten
trying to grow to twenty how did you
haven't before there will it took
probably a year to get promoted so next
I will happily measure that on will
Billings
well no values and like yeah yeah but
one thing we did was so you put you've
got to put yourself into the mindset of
millennial why we've mentioned before
you know if you need some new earphones
you can get an order from Amazon on the
day you know leave a swipe left or right
on ting that done which way is bought
but the point is you can get everything
straight away yeah
any business now that has progression
for a my annual is going to take 12
months minimum for me you're gonna lose
people really because they're gonna be
disengaged they're gonna want to know
than that so big thing that we did was
put a step change role in the middle so
give them a promotion give them a title
maybe to give an extra grand doesn't
have to be a massive amount financially
but give them someone to work towards or
six months and then in another six
months they've achieved what they would
have done over 12 but they feel like
they've been wise and that's one big
thing that I would say if you're gonna
hire graduates give them shorter objects
is to work towards because a month
sorry a year which probably like ten
years in a graduate and Ansari Iowa
especially in the world of a recruiter
right or someone that's early on because
those first 12 months could feel like
yes do you not I mean like it can be
really difficult you're giving in that
first year so I think that's such a
great point then it's so you typically
done it on Billings Benin also saw them
demonstrating the values and living and
breathing them and these days yeah
there's Nicole's probably yeah I'd say
we start that everyone is a resource
that and so it's all about placements
for them but there's so many different
things they've got to deliver on and
what we're looking for is is conversion
rates more than anything else so getting
candidates to the training day and being
picked out so we're working on have we
invested into the right people so it's
all about qualities though values is
probably the big one we've actually had
people where we've promoted based the
fact that they've actually delivered on
all of those things but not necessarily
on the Billings but ticked all the
others but went way and beyond in all
the other areas so for us the value that
they're contributing to the business is
far greater than just a revenue target
and is that because you know if they
keep working at those metrics and those
conversions and also it's just setting a
good example
I think we're in a team where people
look to other people as to where should
I go next and I think if I've got
someone who's sitting a great example of
what what we're looking for is a great
recruit in our business then you want
people to look to them and go actually
they've been promoted why they've been
promoted what is it they're doing that I
need to replicate there's also a piece
on this and this
again I figure they don't a previous
podcast you know people because the
billion really well it means they can
mentor or manage resources or they're
getting for the team for me it's
completely the wrong move what what
we've created is and a lot business
South a so it's not unique but you know
you can go down the individual bill as
much and make as much money as a
one-room or you can go down the team
leader route but there's a key
difference here that the team leader
root means that your objectives aren't
just based on Billings yeah because if
you create somebody that's gonna be a
team leader that all their focus about
is their own Billings then are they
going to be the right person to
municipal team so values you know the
way that they mentor for people you know
help out or for people the team is
probably as important as their billions
if they're going to go into management
but I think it's the point as you made
like if you don't have the option and
your recruitment business right now then
that's one you should definitely not
kind of a joke by these qui qui
management you know hence why I came out
recruitment after ten months because I
got an opportunity to manage that's all
I've ever wanted to do and the calls are
flip side of that she doesn't you've got
to find people what they got out where
the girls were they going to get to it
we could all be successful doing either
side of things we don't like we are
going to be more successful and reach
your potential if you do what you like
yeah and what would be good to get both
your opinions on is cuz I mean they're
they'll definitely be so many people
listening that hire for their business
or high for their team or whatever and
hire the top of people that you speak to
where where do you recruitment agencies
really get it wrong when hiring grads to
know I mean what do they do
where do they get it really wrong where
you can really just sort of communicate
some of the things that you know grads
don't really really don't appreciate
other night do some of the common
mistakes that you hear and see
recruiting agencies may when it comes to
hiring a lot of young talent without any
experience
I've been really honest worried they'll
be really honest with it it comes down
to training development and I know
that's that's our USP but I'm not
pitching for us what it really needs to
have is if you want to take on a
graduate you are going to have to train
and develop them okay and that means
that you can't expect in the first year
you're gonna get return
you can't expect that they're going to
be great at BD within a year you can't
expect that they're going to be smashing
the candidate piece you've got to give
them training development particularly
for that first year of employment every
recruitment business may say we've got
great training but if we're really
honest with ourselves and look at our
business have we got great training
we've got the support I think that's
fair you're going to recruit somebody
that you back because they smash their
interviews but if you don't support them
and train them never going to be graded
it so for me whether you use external
providers or you have a dedicated
trainer or you've got somebody who can
really mentor this not just applicable
for billing all the time then that for
me is a great start and unfortunately so
challenge because a lot of our
businesses you know predominantly we
work with Assamese right remember
businesses you know tend to be you know
the large missouri employer absolutely
so you know we're really helping develop
them and we'll always give them advice
is don't take a punt on someone that you
can't support you know get the sport in
place and they'll be more likely to be
successful how long should I know we'll
see like you can't dis or give a blanket
answer but liar how long should these
people expect to life
I'm if I'm serious about hiring for my
business and I'm not for hiring grads or
people just some sales experience
whatever how long should I give these
people you know I mean if you're I mean
someone with a sales experience again it
depends what type of sales experience it
is right so firstly I suppose is someone
with experience you're going to expect
things from sooner no obviously a
graduate you're gonna have to be really
realistic this is about long term
planning you know it's only now that
we're kind of I suppose more so for
Manchester's point of view you know one
thing's absolutely smashing it at the
moment and will overtake Manchester
naturally because of the because the
fees generated here and higher salaries
what Manchester's you know so establish
now that you know it's an expectation
now the
targets are smashed and delivered on but
we also need to continue to develop
people at the same time and I think
that's the biggest challenge no matter
if you're a one employee 10 20 or 50 the
trainer's support has to be there yeah I
think what's really interesting at that
point now and I think you've probably
done podcast with so many people that
said the same thing they don't bill they
look they're some of the most successful
recruiters had the worst first six
months ever or the worst first year ever
yet they've ended up literally been best
performers top builders and managing
directors and I think that's what people
have to remember is that not everyone's
going to hit the ground running from day
one you've got to give them a bit of
time we had a conversation with a client
a few months ago and a couple of the
candidates were a couple of months in
and they're like well I'm not sure I'm
not sure and I might think back to why
you hired them in the first place
what can you be doing differently it's
ensure they can perform and now they're
doing great but it's sometimes you panic
don't you you're not seeing anything
about quick enough when you go right
they're not performing get them out get
someone else to I mean I guess sometimes
like from the context you're talking
about there was some that's some really
good advice makes you remember why are
these people all you saw in them
essentially you can quietly forget that
one down pay and if it on the board for
three months but then on top of that as
well what my own personal experience
when I was in the business of eight
people and sat direct authority that's
the owner of the business was
demonstrating the right activities and
he's like so what was yeah what should
they what key things that they should be
looking out for just something we talk
about this a lot especially when we're
training and we train graduates change
my train managers as well is that we all
know this two things is will in their
skill and I don't expect them to have
that skill for the first six twelve
months I expect to have the wheel so if
they're demonstrating the right work I
think the right attitude the right focus
they're going outside the day to try and
learn about the market they're showing
all the riot traits then I know and I'm
confident and we can develop them yeah
if they're not showing that then I'd be
concerned and that's when you can tell
that's fair you know we've so we're not
going to name names but we've got a
couple of really strong people that
probably wasn't here where we want them
to hit and bought twelve months in now
by a little bit more support bit more
development just because they were
working harder and showing earlier that
they're now successful so you've got to
be willing to give time and don't get me
wrong we manage your business so you
know we'll I know what my business
there's got to be a point you know we
were two targets there has to be a
return because that's what recruitment
about would be realistic for the first
year just be realistic and give training
support and you'd be amazed the
retention rates will improve but
training support has to be given and I
think I'll just be you know he's great
recruitment so sit with him he's gonna
be a structured training program and you
will see your retention rates improve
hmm so 50 of prime then on the mission
to change perception of recruitment
sales
I'll see what you want in the wood this
year as well there are no you're really
proud of and how do you think you're
doing against this mission of yours to
change the perception okay I think well
we've trained three and a half thousand
really a Juris now on recruitment in
sales so that's three and a half
thousand people that have gone away with
some skills they didn't have when we met
them so I think that's a massive massive
leap forward his recruitment sales don't
get we actually wrote a blog and after
not winning the award we won three years
ago that came up that that first year
and it's late its recruitment it's not
sales numbers like recruit many sales so
I wrote a blog on it afterwards there
wasn't no recruitment means being
someone that worked in sales more so
than recruitment I would honestly say
recruitment is really interesting so you
may may or may not have seen did a live
event not too long ago and this came up
because I think we spoke a lot around
recruitment becoming a profession and
and it's sort of definitely going that
way and that's that's what we want for
the industry but a lot was spoken about
and being being consultative I didn't
value these types of things and I think
when we didn't talk about setting it
sells it did get quite a bit of pushback
that
no it's been consulting these types of
things do you not I mean so I personally
I personally really think recruitment in
sales and I don't know I just don't
understand how you could not say that I
think if you're if you think sales is
then just pushing people in a corner to
take a job that they don't want then
yeah that definitely isn't how it should
be but for me it was all why I got into
it was I wanted to expand on my sales
skills which it definitely helped me
today and now it's because I went from a
real transactional environment to this
or more consultative environment in
recruitment but I don't know I think
there is a real conversation there
around because I'm sure you see a lotta
bits with added value where consultative
and this sells is less used that's still
selling yeah I agree
and I think that's the thing it's easy
to label on sales and go that's selling
but ultimately fact finding solutions
selling all those things it's still part
of the process it's still part of the
sales process you uncover requirement
you find out what's going on you
question a lot you're really inquisitive
and then you're going to know what we
can help you with that
so you're influencing your negotiating
your it's everything is selling it's a
different form of selling so you know
I'm a Salesman I've gotta be honest
my biggest challenge going into
recruitment was the length of the
process yeah being someone who likes the
same repetitive kind of pitch being more
transactional was was for me what sales
is it's a lot more transactional these
quick areas kind of deal deal deal and
recruitment probably the more senior you
get into it as well there's a lot slower
paced so you've got to be more patient
and consultative so I do believe it is
different but if anything and I would
say it's probably the most challenging
of all sales roles because you are
dealing with both sides yeah candidate
and client so you're actually doing more
selling than anyone else you just have
to be a bit more consultative in your
approach so why do you think you won
this award what's the name of the world
cuz I'm clearly apologies yeah
so the award is the the basement wards
which support by the is M so the
Institute sales management it's probably
the most prestigious Stellar's Awards so
is there was no
yeah and it's sales touring provider of
the year so yeah what do you think and
the cool things that contribute to that
obviously some amazing stats are the
amount of people even if acted yeah what
what contributes to that why do you
think I'll take that because Nicole
doesn't like it so I think there's two
there's two key things firstly we've got
a unique concept the is M this year
really bought into it
usually recruitment businesses won't win
any form of sales awards so to win that
as a recruitment business and there's a
business that's doing something
different yes what they backed and
that's all about getting young people
into sales and recruitment as a career
so I think our concept of training
candidates before and after they get the
job and the 90% success rate is key
however the biggest factor of it and
Nicole won't like to admit it is Nicole
and so three years of trying to win the
award and if people want to talk about
resilience being told three times the
you know recruitment isn't saying yeah
or being put back because maybe you're
dealing at the graduate and then
actually you know we want to talk about
people you know training senior leaders
of the industry and being told that and
then still going back three times over
and winning the award I think he's true
testament to her and all our training
concepts our models are written by
Nicole so won't miss the way that the 90
percent success rate is down to the
training we deliver but the training is
only good as the content that you have
yeah so Nicole weighs is a massive
factor in that as well as did the unique
concept that we're really proud of
that's wicked okay well yeah I think I
think it was a different year this year
obviously we've got five years behind us
and we're proven now I think the
challenge the last few years you're
competing with Robby in the wrong awards
to be honest we're in an award where
it's all about businesses that are sales
training businesses and we're different
because we were recruitment and training
company so we were the only business
that came along where we are not hundred
percent sales training we are 5050 and
this year I think being able to get
across the fact that actually we're at
pointing out where we've changed so many
people's career options to get them
successful in a
that perhaps they hadn't even considered
and getting more people into industry
and think being able to highlight that
probably the biggest challenges this
industry faces attracting and then
retaining the best talent and being able
to do what we do and add that little bit
of value that actually takes their
career to success rather than failure I
think this year we were able to really
show and demonstrate the achievements
that we had and that's probably what got
us to the win Nicole where do you think
a lot of people get super huge partners
you said there was the content and you
said me spoke a lot of things you do I
mean let you dance share all the secrets
but like where do you think a lot of
trainers get it wrong because I think
all right I just think little
conversation at recently I'm speaking to
a chap and I was talking him some
business he's like yeah like trainers
like some of them are great but there's
a lot crap ones that because I always
think like if you're good at what you do
why would you why would you stop doing
that so like I don't know where yeah
yeah well you know you've kind of just
hit the nail on the head I think and a
lot of its credibility I still do the
job every day so I still speedy every
day I still register candidates every
day I take feedback and manage the
process so I think the fact that I still
do it every day means that I can relate
to the people that I'm training I I
suppose the only advantage that I have
is that I've been doing a hell of a lot
longer so I hear a lot less notes than
they'll hear but I can educate around
that so I think that's probably one of
the reasons why and I also famous
modernization if I think I'm in armed
only six months in but if I think the
credibility that I get is I have to
practice what I preach so one arm speak
when I'm patient people and how we've
got to that conversations they're
sending me a message and they're not
getting on the course well this is won't
help your guys and girls with like I
have to practice what I preach that this
is yeah this is how we've got to this
point so I think that is such a valid
point and I think that is why there is
some of that sort of cynical Ness
attached to it is that because that
for five years so I think yeah I think
I'm seeing the other reason I think a
lot of people who feed this back to me
who I was like they they go off they do
the training and then there's no
follow-up I normally set up what's that
groups with anyone that's coming the
training group so they're not me from
the same business and then we book him
roleplay practice their following few
weeks so there's a common saying that
it's 28 days to change a habit or create
a new habit or behavior so the
implementation piece is I know how busy
managers are I know how busy recruits
are so I know how hard it is you get
these people back they've had the
training and now we're meant to manage
it and implement it but it's a
partnership so why work in partnership
with our clients and go right this is
the content we're gonna be training this
is how they're gonna need to be managed
when they come back these are things you
need to get them doing so they will have
action plans and I'll then cool them
probably two or three times over the
next few weeks and get them to roleplay
me or or book in their diary that they
call me and they just pitch to me like
I'm a recruiter or anyone and it's that
repetition that practice that I think
makes a difference because they're
continuously then developing then
they'll come back and maybe have a fresh
training as well but I do think if I'm
honest I think you probably agree it's
the fact that you still do the job that
you get a lot more engagement at buying
and I think it's the delivery as well
there's nothing worse than being on a
five-day training program that's quite
generic you just get bored Indian
especially people that are quite
impatient if your recruitment you want
things to happen you want to be doing
things so we do our training and bite
size chunks so we do much more shortened
versions let them take a bit of learning
go and apply it then come back and add
to it rather than just throw it all at
them in one go stick so we look a common
area where quite a lot thinking of
smaller businesses that I'm sure I'd
love some at least at how many
recruitment businesses don't have
someone dedicated training there's be a
lot so I guess is a common thing that
you see that follow up as you said I
know some common things and they're 28
days to form a new habit whatever but I
feel like I think the trend that I had
when I was in recruitment and it would
be very split are done training
completed there and then you don't
revisit that yes a month late or
whatever is that a big
a lot definitely wrong I think the
biggest gap in the success part of the
whole process is getting your managers
or your mentors trained on how to to
coach and feedback it's not even making
canvas just there's two types of
feedback there's developmental feedback
and motivational feedback so as soon as
people start going around constructive
criticism no thing else people don't
want to be criticized too normally in
Macroom we've got egos we don't like to
be criticized what we're looking for is
feedback that's going to go you know
what we could have done differently
there or let's look at that call so that
they're constantly learning but if they
did do a great cool be praised for it
but tell them why it was great so they
reinforce its name ABI it's little
things with feedback on the job that
makes the biggest biggest difference so
the implementations far quicker and so
right do if you listen right now and
your manager or does your management I
know that those two things and I've been
doing it not sure yeah that's so
important isn't it and I think another
thing as well that we've spoken a lot
about on here is which sort of ties in
state he said about my motivational
feedback I think what's your sort of
view on actually understand potato I can
imagine particularly grads as well as
like do you actually know what makes
that person tick and one they're
motivated by as you said a lot that's
changed a lot it's not just money
I'll see you tell me on to buy that
house like did you know I mean it's like
do you actually know what they're
motivated by cuz that's yeah what was
part of that feedback as well right yeah
it's really interesting okay cool so
future prime then now now a bit more
structuring I'm a bit of the plan I
guess so
five years running a recruitment
business what did you have you liked
what was what do you think we spoke a
lot quite a lot about the positive so I
guess what would have been some of the
biggest challenges he's spoken about
YouTube always had to work on
relationship I'm sure that's an ongoing
process but any other sort of big
challenges that the both of you maybe
share that you think other people could
benefit from more likely go through
now I think I'd be so many lessons
running a recruitment business that we
get challenged with day to day I'd say
things that I'd say is people will try
and get in your way to success one big
bits advice is just don't don't let get
in your way just keep going do what you
do
don't be structured from what you're
good at and people may say that you
don't do what you do but you do do so as
long as you know you're true to yourself
keep going I think also everyone talks
about recruitment rollercoaster it is
well-named
and it's true but I think you have to be
that person that goes that is just
recruitment recruitment is not plain
sailing your product is people so you're
going to get surprises along the way
nothing's straight forwards it's having
the right mentality of having a real
deep-rooted reason why you want to be
successful knowing what that is so then
we have a bad day the next day you get
up and you crack on but you've got to
know why why you want to keep going and
I think that's been our biggest thing is
that we have a very clear vision of what
you want to achieve and it is tough at
times like this certain times you work
it's really tough there's certain
challenges that come along that's just
part and parcel of what we do is
accepting that that is recruitment and
there's a reason why it's so highly
rewarded if you are successful there's a
reason why there's such great incentives
in place because it's tough and when you
do well you deserve to be rewarded for
it because you go through the tough
stuff to get to the good stuff I think
you can there's so many challenges in
there but without going into the
specifics to me the biggest challenge of
always mindset yeah it's going to be
tough and when you set up a business and
it's not just the two of you anymore and
there's 20 people in the business that
you know I believe in that business and
believing in you your mindset is going
to be challenged every single day so the
best big advice that I would give to
anybody is you've got to have a mindset
that's positive and that's going to be
really hard it's gonna be challenged
things you can do you know I run every
single morning first thing I do before I
do anything and
I don't do that for fitness I do that
pure win simply so that I'm fresh and I
come into the day after a really bad day
the day before ready with the right
behavior mm-hmm
we talked about a lot belief behavior
resort what you believe affects you
behavior affects a resort and if you've
got a positive mindset it's going to
help so I think the biggest challenge of
all is keeping in a positive place and
if you do that you know you're halfway
there to being successful and how have
you gone about cultivating and your
people because that's that's so
important right it's it's easy for you
guys you know your mission you own the
business like how how because there'll
be a lot of people see the challenges
that love only salary managers have is
like having that feeling of a lot are
like why can't why doesn't they get as
much as I do and want they work as hard
as I'm working you know I mean so I
guess have you saw cultivated that that
top and one sitting in your people well
firstly you gotta lead by example you
know I think we we you know if I'm
completely honest you know and this is
feedback I got from the coal actually I
became a bit complacent at one point if
these things are going so well and and
and then you know deals after deals and
it's great with smashing targets and
then all of a sudden it's like alright
well you know it could probably leave at
four o'clock today or I could probably
go and do this or whatever then quite
quickly you get told that that's not the
way the way if you wanna live stab
solutely if you don't you know being
really honest with it that's something
to happen to me and and then my team and
become complacent because you come
complacent so actually the stuff that
we've been across whether you're a
graduate or whether you twenty years
into your career
the work ethic thing doesn't change yeah
if anything that that's why a career in
recruitment isn't about it's gonna be
hard for 12 months you know it's going
to be the hardest it's gonna be hard for
your career you've gotta be willing to
throw yourself into it so for me you
you've got to make sure that you're
willing to do that I think I always say
a success does come at a price you do
have to make sacrifices to make a
successful business and if you if you
want a real successful business that
unfortunate is going to be okay just
look for the first
years in the business Nicole's got a
young family and she was in Manchester
you know helping drive it and she lives
in London so and how's that the
difference is changing and my kids are
quite young men they're bit older now so
it was challenging back there now 11 and
8 but my daughter she was 3 when we
first started crying so yeah it's
challenging but I've got a good support
network so that's the point and I think
you know again people setting out in
recruitments they don't put business or
in the early stage he's now thinking why
am I not growing well you've got to
think are you giving it everything are
you making a sacrifices because I assure
you there's someone that is and when
people look at competition thing well
why they do so well well generally comes
down to probably sacrifice more and
probably working a bit harder and once
you have that reality check which you
know something that I did you get back
on get back onto the train and you get
the growth again and you haven't in you
to be successful just a quick one on
that point Nicole about raising a family
just because actually you may not do you
know Louise McMullen white-label
yeah yeah at the power yeah so yeah so
shared a podcast of her recently and yes
she spoke a lot of rounds she had a one
in rod when she start our recruitment
business but she started on recruitment
business just because she was pitching
to everyone that she could build 150 km
four days she had to work four days
which got a young child and her but not
many people did that and a loved one you
could build under 50 km for days and we
basically spoke a lot about raising a
family while running a recruitment
business and grown in recruitment
business so I guess just a quick one
than that just because I've got quite a
lot of messages recently from mums who
have started recruitment be the sender
hm if you get anyone there has done I'd
love you to talk to them more talk a bit
about just because I think yeah again
talk about sacrifice I mean Louie shared
her story that her plan was very much go
up in the morning do this
we'll run were come back do these types
of things and then she'd be doing all of
our admin for the next day until 2 I am
she did that for a good couple of years
right yeah typically hear that do you
know I mean so I guess what yeah how how
did you deal with that over that
particular period of raising a young
family anything to I think it I think
it's really challenging it's especially
when they're young and you feel like
guilt there's a lot of guilt and then
there's lot of I suppose outside opinion
of you're not a good mom because you
never see your kids and they sent me
other end I might was okay for a dad to
do it a dad can go out to work for long
hours and not see the kids but it's not
okay for mums do it and there's
definitely exception I'm really
fortunate that I've got a really good
balance in my family so I'm lucky enough
that my husband can be there and do a
lot of the mum stuff and that was a
decision we made when we decided that
this was the path to go down and I think
it is difficult but I do think it's more
challenging in the early days because
you are working so hard to make a
business success that you genuinely feel
you've got to work longer hours to make
it happen so you are literally getting
home pictum spared to staying up late
but it doesn't go on forever I wouldn't
say I stopped working when I get home
far I'm much more organized and I think
the more you do it the more organized
you become and then you start to get
much better balance and I'd say now I
definitely have a better balance I don't
miss a school pride I miss forwards day
email from the Col 11 my p.m. what would
your advice be just like I guess there
is going to be lighting I love anyway I
think remember why you're doing it new
ways is that to me all the time when
you're having a tough time or you find
it difficult you're feeling guilty
always remember why you're doing it and
always try and find some time so I'll
always make sure at least one of my days
that weekend is literally just don't
pick up your phone don't check your
emails don't do this don't do that
because I think it is important
otherwise you do loser
a little bit of why you're doing and
then why do it they're hundreds my idea
and actually now when they get the nice
Christmas presents in the nice sheets
they don't mind so if you make a good
point around the opinions piece
obviously obviously but I can see that
and I think that's a really important
part to point out as well as that if
you'd know exactly why you're doing then
you just treat yourself and ya get good
at blocking out those opinions because
I'd be honest I hate it I don't think I
spoke about my kids probably for the
first two four years in the business
really barely mentioned them that and I
never bring them up and if a client was
talking about the kids never mention
them because I always felt like there
was a stigma attached to it and all
right you've got kids therefore you
can't be a finger changed I think now I
don't know if it was more my problem and
I saw it as an issue whereas now it's
not an issue at all like they've been
into the office like I talk to my
clients about this so I think it it
could have been my view but yeah a
hundred percent for the first two three
years I never even mentioned them a lot
of people were surprised when they found
out I did have kids that's crazy
mmm I think just you said as well I
think when you were saying about making
sure you always have like a day
dedicated kids whatever a thing a really
important point to add is like when you
are with your kids a lot are you
actually with your kids
my so got mean you could both be moms
and you say ah I've saw my kids five
hours this week and I'll say laughs 150
now this week that doesn't necessarily
mean that you've had more time with them
you know yeah I think that's a such a
good point to make Massachusetts in
general like not to be the parent like
are you actually there with your kids
and given me a full attention 7:00 to
9:00 10:00 p.m. or whatever it is yeah
it may not be as long but you know I
mean I think that's such an important
point to add as well yeah definitely and
I think when you are starting a business
it's a lot harder because your time is
definitely dedicated to driving that and
so I arrange got to take the call but I
think you learn very quickly that you've
got to get a good balance and now when I
did through that door I try and get my
cools down beforehand and then and
anything I need to pick up a try and get
it done after they've gone to bed or at
least I've had a good hour of just find
out how their days been and what they've
been up to or breaking them up when
they're having a fine
yeah absolutely love that that's amazing
so wait just just quickly I guess then
before we finish your stuff I think it'd
be great once you be started around as
you said know you wanted to you had big
targets for the first year and stuff how
have you done how was the business
growing in terms of revenue and stuff
over the last couple years how does that
look because I think it's very easy for
people to say how is that how is that
being yeah well we we've we've grown
every year between 50 to 60% we you know
so and obviously a lot of businesses
talk about turnover but you know the big
learning from our non-exact was you know
it's more it's all about your
operational profit absolutely we've got
we want to kind of get our operating
profit be quite open with thatis at 400
K operating profit at the moment we want
to get that to a million pound in the
next three years and for us that's what
it's all about in terms that was very
soft it's fluctuating but it typically
gone in the right yeah we were fortunate
to do like you know six-figure profit in
our first year really know we're
turnover was lower 250 K we did 100
every year we've been able to grow that
and that's pretty much you know what
what we're trying to achieve from a
financial point of view we want to work
open third office which we'll be doing
in 2020 really was up in Leeds is it
okay so we look at graduates and we're
graduate want to state so we have to
look at what our universities are good
in terms of and what city to people stay
Astri so you know london obviously
people and study here they want to work
in manchester second city really in
terms of where people want to stay Leeds
has actually got one of the highest
retention rates of people that she
studying leaders say I want to work in
Leeds so for us if people are going to
stay in the area course it is so we do
the studies based on that so it's
cheaper in the north
and it's it's a great it's a great city
it's a great place it's vibrant so you
know how my should be no sunder my first
client leaves actually the other week so
it's cool there's a load of recruitment
business in lead so we look at where our
clients in terms of our target basis war
so god what clients we work with in
Manchester on one than that have quite
bases there and we look at where
graduates going to stay and if those too
much and that's that gives us a good
again it's just like I know it sounds
basic and simple but like it's the right
instead of just open a new office for
the Open Office sake and bit of an ego
fitting light that's the right answer
that you should be answering around I'm
hoping the office in this place because
the the grads than the retention stuff
like that I've been I just think so it's
only people are prone to just opening
and headcount and all that just for the
headcount sake and open opening office a
that's exciting then yeah is we we have
to do that because we're proud of our
process of training people so if we're
going to train candidates as well as
place them then they need to be in
touching distance so actually that's why
city's a great location for us we've
also talked model on the road as well so
we're doing prime pop ups so we're we're
taking our training day model and for
clients that may be in different
locations that we can't service out of
Manchester in London and doing pop-up
training days for them resourcing for
that area and do training days on-site
at their company which is proven really
successful as well so yeah though we
want to continue to look at you know 50
60 percent growth year-on-year
and so how how do you think obviously
with what you're doing you're definitely
making a dent and impact but how do you
think we can change the perception of
creepin and sales you know I mean how
what else can we be doing obviously what
you what you guys are doing is brilliant
what else do you think we can be doing I
think be be proud about it you know I
think if you're in the states and you
say you're a Salesman you know they
think you regard whereas in the UK
people are hiding it because the first
thing you think of is PPI sales or
something yeah you know that's a form of
selling but we all have to start
somewhere so I think firstly being proud
of being in sales and being in
recruitment also making sure it's not
just about money
no there's gotta be really value that we
had I think is really important and most
importantly in
in people through training development
can train people on it they'll become
good at it and that's what we're all
about I think a bit yeah I think if I
think of the conversation ad and stuff
the amount of people that have sort of
been chucked in the recruitment machine
and it's smoked out because of sheer
training and all that sort of stuff
those people will then end up work a few
clients probably at some point or weapon
that's that's just great massive
internet in terms of just more those
people go in the end recruitment [ __ ]
horrible how hard recruitment is if
you're not training them how to do well
it isn't great you're not gonna enjoy it
yeah whereas if you are getting the
skills you get in told her do you're
shown how to do the job and then you
give it going it works then you're gonna
go actually it's a great career because
the rewards are unreal but you know it's
not gonna be perfect every day and I
think it's the reality check we've got
to be more honest with people from the
outset that gynie is in all these
wonderful things yes the incentives are
gray yes the money is amazing but you're
gonna have to work really bloody hard to
make it happen and it's not going to
happen overnight and I think it's the
transparency around it that's so
important you said yourself a lot of
people talk about the positives but
don't really talk about the challenges
that come with it
if we can get the challenges across as
well you definitely definitely changing
the perception of the industry for sure
just a quick one because before we
finish no actually the final question
just have a curiosity war em what do you
think costs some of the sort of best
incentives that you seen at the mark at
the moment of interest cuz like there's
something I should add incentives like I
spoke with a chap called Joe and we were
talking about how he just like despises
recruitment agencies who promote working
for them by uncap Commission it's like
when is commission ever cat laia it's
just other night you know I mean just
stuff like that and I guess like I think
it's come up a few times around free
fruit like wise up you know I mean what
obviously you know these people you know
what sort of what they're driven by it
particularly also young people so what
do you think of something this or better
sensors that you've seen so far there of
caught your right attention thing you
definitely need a balance of T so they
need their individual incentives but
collaborative team incentive seem to
work really really well as well and free
breakfast seems to be very popular yeah
I think we've you've got a happy
financial weed sensei so we have them on
a monthly quarterly and biannual basis
Millennials making it quick but also as
well as that we have team incentives so
for example we have a lot of people do
monthly target hitting's which great for
individuals and so on we also have like
team target hitting so for example if
the team hits a target everybody goes
out to celebrate even if maybe one
person is missed and that's to create
the right values because we're always
going to have a bad month but if your
team members pull you through then it
raises team yeah so I think you've got
our having senses that are team based
whatever they are whatever the rewards
as well as individual and you know we go
away once a year and the whole business
goes based on it and I think that's
important rather than just individuals
it's the whole company if the company
has a good year and that creates a right
bow is such an important trip those toss
drifts oh it's great it's great but I
think for us but my biggest frustration
sometimes is people miss out even though
they've performed quite well they might
have had a tougher year and whatever but
they still done quite well as maybe
still been profitable you know for me
you've got to give them the opportunity
to attend with the team that's helping
along the way because next year they
might go over and above and smash it so
I think you've got to have a balance
between individual and team but you know
the stereotypical kind of ones away you
know nights out kind of incentives
obviously worked really well because the
social environment yeah so I think I've
seen quite a lot of feelings recently a
rattle see and just the CSR a lot of
agencies I think I've really liked some
that and stuff and I think just a final
point because I think I'm see you guys
are well positioned to talk about air
commissioned structures it's a good
Commission structure today's market an
honest one yeah explain in how the
Commission structure works and and you
know for example really clear we need
our resources doing a minimum
two deals based in the market we're in
and we want to do in at least three
deals a month and we're really clear
with the fact of that's because the two
deals pays for your desk and the free
deals were starting to make money from
so when you explain the way commission
structures work and how the business
makes money them then you can understand
the levels of it at the same time it's
also gotta be attractive you know
because we're not paying high basics we
don't believe that people should be here
for a basic salary we believe they
should be here to go out and earn
Commission obviously so it's got to be
rewarding enough to do that yeah I think
the best commission structure is the
ones that are simple people can
calculate what they're going to learn
quite quickly I think as soon as they
got complex then people think there's a
hidden agenda behind it and people want
to know very quickly if I do this this
is what I'm gonna learn everyone says
well this is my this is my book bear
with that is I think that's why we need
to be honest now again it's another tip
and I know we go through it because you
know we've been through for five years
but we've been quite fortunate that
where we add things in and don't take
away so for example if you go out what
people do when they try and attract
staff at the start by the way weak
routing stuff at the early stage for me
is the easiest time crew crew is when
you get to 20 heads or pause ways harder
to recruit because then your recruitment
business it's not offering the same
dream has been one of the first
candidacy so really when you're two or
three people in for me that's the best
time the easiest time to recruit because
grudges want that progression
opportunities become a leader in the
business share options whatever yeah but
the Commission schemes if you're gonna
say it's the best you know I'm paying
you 30% or whatever some of these
schemes go hook to which is huge then
when you do grow and your overhead to
grow you're gonna have to start taking
that away because a business can't make
money if the paying levels that high and
where some entrepreneurs have made that
mistake he's pay out too much too soon
and then all of a sudden when someone's
a year in you say you're going to earn
well less commission so for me go steady
and build every we had something in
every year
so every year we add in some things of
this year we've added in a biannual wish
list and that's basically will pay up to
a certain amount we'll buy you something
that's on your wish list someone wants
to go to New York so you want some
mulberry handbag yeah we'll buy that for
you in this object and that's a lot that
someone's come in this year so he's
fresh its new people I've got something
new I think that's such good advice add
to it don't take away absolutely it's
really important yeah I think that's a
really good point and cool so last
question I have for you both last
question is if you could communicate to
every single recruit out there they
would listen to your advice they would
take it on then implement it could be a
phrase could be a word what comes to
mind if everyone was listening at their
prime what would you say to these people
I'd say invest in talent hundreth in
yeah what would I say to them um I would
say to them be proud about what you're
doing mm-hmm I still think the you know
there's a stigma attached to recruitment
sales it really books me yeah I think
it's an amazing career some amazing
recruiters out there that then go on to
be successful as entrepreneurs because
sales gives them skills to do that
yeah so for me be proud about what you
do in a most important believe in it mmm
because if you believe in yourself you
you know as cheesy as it sounds you're
already halfway there yeah I know what
are people fail just because they didn't
believe they could in the first place so
for me that's that's the biggie
no no cars been a pleasure